You don't have to work increases and
decreases at the edge of your knitting.
In this example, we're going to increase
in the center of the knitting for a
bust dart in a sideways knit sweater.
We'll be using a garter bar to
move a large number of stitches.
Start by marking the needle
that will be used for reference.
To keep from dropping stitches, hang
a three-prong tool on the needles
to the left of the marked needle.
Just let it hang, remove the group
of stitches on the garter bar.
Move them one needle to the
right, leaving an emptied needle.
Then rehang the stitches
from the garter bar.
Pick up the butt of a stitch in the
row below to fill the empty needle.
One stitch has been increased.
Following your knitting instructions.
Repeat the increase for as many
times as needed for your pattern.
To work decreases in the middle of the
knitting, start by transferring the Mark
stitch to the left, leaving an emptied
needle, hanging that three-prong tool
will keep the stitches from popping off.
Then remove the group of
stitches on the garter bar,
shift them to the left,
filling in that emptied needle.
Take the newly emptied needle
to out of work position.
And you will have decreased a stitch
in the middle of the knitting.
Following your knitting
instructions, repeat the decrease
for as many times as needed.